Alissa uh was like Hey I want to talk to
you about something I want to tell you
something promise you won't get mad and
I was like just stop right there first
of all never going to make a promise
like that cuz that might get mad and
second of all let's just have the
conversation on the show and you were
like not so sure you want to do that I
think it'll be helpful for other people
to listen to because I know the
difference our relationship versus the
mass majority and the reaction most
people would get I feel like and that
can
create toxicity and I feel like you're
going to have your own opinions and
that's what I'm also here to listen to
is also hear you out and hear your
opinions but I feel like you're going to
have a healthier um reaction than most
parents might and it could be helpful
for other people to listen to including
parents right there right there right
there he's just what she's saying she's
like oh what are you going to say what
is just get to your for other
people to listen to including parents
are you moving out of state oh God get
to your offensive statement it's not
offensive that's you yeah it just get
your just do it just do it Nike Nike
just come on that's when your kid starts
rambling before they just came home late
at night it's like what what you do well
it's you know like okay don't be you
need to promise you want get mad okay so
listen what do you want to say listen
okay so you know my friend Mike and you
star like you Mikey's a piece of
and you already warn this
not to hang out with Mikey done 10 times
why you with Mike wait hold on hold on I
was not with Mikey and mom said I could
go out but Mikey was there and there was
drugs you're guilty eat it on the
just me up first we're going to get that
out of the way and then after that we
could talk get the anger out yeah you
know what a lot of my com ation with my
parents would have worked out a lot much
better if I would be like you know me
up cuz I used to have to hear a whole
ass talk but you already know it's
coming at the end it's like listen
you're going to beat my a yeah me up
yeah we'll talk after so I've kind of
joked about it
before starting and only
fans but it's it's also not what you
think
either I would be taking a more model
route um in that way we obviously have a
little bit of a presence together so I
want to get your opinions and thoughts
and I also want to tell you but I also
feel like I have assets that I could
capitalize on and call assets that's a
wild way to talk to your parents about
your body I don't care what nobody says
there's no play I don't care how
Progressive you are talking about like
you know what the thing is my assets to
your parents is weird and I know a lot
of you viewers already agree with me
yeah before you agree with me a lot of
y'all also come from weird backgrounds
we're talking about anything sexual is
always tle and that's also really
weird cuz a lot of be out here
in these streets doing a bunch of dirty
business and you can never I don't I
come from the same background you can
never make anything but this end of the
spectrum is also really weird to me
where it's like you can talk about
anything I'm a Busom you taught me to be
a Busom um and I have my boundaries as
well as my own adult there are a lot of
things that I won't do but there's also
you know some modeling I would love to
do anyway
so there's
that you know I love
you I respect you I R I wish I had Sons
raised you to be independent to be like
you said to be business-minded to be
logical and I guess the biggest thing is
you being safe like having a daughter
already knowing that you're highly
likely to be assaulted or or hit or
groped or something like that that's
already on on a a a father's mind when
he has a girl so there's that protection
part of me that's like I don't want you
to be opened up to even more people
stalking or chasing you or doing stuff
because
bro you should have thought of that
before you put her on your podcast you
thought that should have thought of that
before she had a Tik Tok with millions
of followers say whatever you want my X
work want them to go against that's fine
but your kids are never going to
experience as much unwanted attention
from weirdos as when they're on social
media and they're popular I've never had
so much unwanted attention from weirdos
as right now yes she's like well known
on Tik Tok or like she has a pretty
large following like that world has
already opened up to her there's a lot
of reasons to not want your kids to do X
work but it seems kind of odd to say
this when you made your kid a little
celebrity mini whatever it is you know
that's what I'm saying I'm like I have
bail
money like I'm willing to straight up go
to prison I know that's already a a
problem that we have to deal with and
then on top of that you being like oh
here's a booby now Bo just a booby a lot
of what I'm feeling is like protection I
don't want you to do something that's
going to make something harder on you
later in life like at when I was 19 I
had I thought I was going to be one
thing in my life completely went in a
different direction what if when you're
37 you decide to run for president or
run for some kind of office or you want
to be taken seriously as an actor in
some major or you want to be an
outspoken you know uh activist in a
certain thing and this comes back to
haunt you maybe Society will grow up and
that kind of stuff won't affect you
negatively but I'm concerned with your
safety I'm concerned with your future
and I don't want you to do anything
that's going to harm future you my fear
is that you would do something now get
money now and then when you're in your
40s you look back on it and go man I
really had an opportunity to do
something bigger with my life and
because that that stuff exist on the
internet now I'm prohibited or
restricted in some other aspect of my
life I I raise you to respect yourself
and to be safe and I mean you're a grown
woman you're going to do what you're
going to do doesn't feel
great but I I love you and I respect you
and if that's what you want to do then I
mean I support you and whatever you want
to do I just really want you to be
careful MH with
said not only your safety but your
future opportunities like you know if
you're going to do something like that
to do it in a way that's classy and
respectful of who you are and not not
ruining future opportunities yeah and
that's where
like go
ahead
um Dad I respect the way you're talking
to your daughter and the way you're able
to have a conversation with that
right um
but I think it's all fun in games until
one of your friends fall on the only
fans of your girl and then it's like
[Applause]
yo
buddy buddy bud
bud I think I saw your daughter out
there she looking mad
good what one of your buddies seen your
girl your daughter on only fans and
reports it to you you might feel
different you might be like yo watch
what watch what you say hey hey hey
watch what you say you can't say that to
everybody all right A lot of people are
going to think that it's your it's your
boys it's your friends it's your homies
they're going to fall on
that you don't understand what I'm
saying okay so you're like oh you have a
daughter she has her only fans and I'm
like yo Abba
I think I saw your daughter on that if
you said it like that we'd have a
problem and I'm okay with us having a
problem because that means you shouldn't
be in my life I understand what you're
any friend who would talk about your
daughter that way you respect to
whatever the she's doing is weird
and probably not somebody you want as a
friend personally understand so at that
point I wouldn't even be thinking about
my daughter that deeply I'd be like yo
who the is this guy cuz you should
never be thinking some weird like
that and if you even did you better keep
that in your head and make
sure you never act on it that's me
personally I don't care what my
daughter's doing I don't care what her
job is there should never be a time you
talking to me like that that's me now
the whole shame associated with people
around you finding out that's very real
and a lot of parents are probably going
to feel that that's facts and there's no
way around that there's no way around it
I think the way he's talking to her is
the thing that makes the most amount of
sense if you want to be involved in your
child's life listen you could disagree
with your kid you can be so against what
your kids doing that you may have to
push them away but acknowledge that at
the end the they're adults they're no
longer just a child right they may be
your child but they're not a child but
it's going to she's forever going to be
my baby she going to be your baby but at
one point in your life she probably
going to wipe your
ass is that really your baby is still so
she you went
wiping it changes the relationship
changes she not a kid I have no problem
under a certain age you got to talk to
them a certain type of way you got to
give them orders okay understand at some
point you going to have to start
changing tools with which you parent
with you can't use physical discipline
or orders or rules the same way you
could as when they're child as when
they've grown into adulthood and your
approach to it has to change and I think
he's taken the most reasonable approach
whilst so basically making his feelings
clear while also saying I still want you
in my life this isn't enough for me to
say you got to go some parents got that
for example I know some parents if you
leave the religion you've left their
life I know some parents if you've
embarrassed them you've left their life
everyone got a different threshold him
it's clearly not meant that for some of
you watching that might be too much your
kid doing some some adult stuff they
can't come home for Thanksgiving or
Christmas or whatever it is me
personally I think I identify with this
man much more than I think a lot of my
viewers because to be honest with you I
feel more Progressive than a lot of
y'all and there's not throw shade at
nobody I just couldn't see myself
throwing away my child or pushing them
out of my life because they did xor I
would disapprove of it strongly I'd be
very much against but I would never push
them away where they no longer felt like
they had a home under my roof right I
feel like there's also a culture of
wanting to school everybody cuz that
culture of people wanting that to happen
especially on social media yeah and
sometimes discourse is just like I'm
talking to you let me I I can disagree
with you without yelling at you I can
disagree with you
without being mad and stuff like that we
can just both Piers agree and be like
you know what I disagree on that point I
don't agree with that I don't have to
scream at you it's it's so
common for people to scream and yell and
be like we disagree and be in a battle
when we
disagree disagreeing with someone
doesn't necessarily equate to that I
think the disagreements sometimes don't
even make sense to me because these guys
are all operating in the comment section
based off of logic it's like you have a
distance from the issue so you can
afford to be like that y when it's your
niece when it's your daughter your son
it's a much difficult diff conversation
and like yeah we say facts or our
feelings blah
but if you think about it family is all
about feelings family is all about
emotional attachment so you can't rid
yourself in that conversation I know
this because like there not a daughter
but I have my niece who's here three
times a week do I think I could distance
myself from somebody I'm that close with
I've Loved I've literally watch when
they're a little person to when they're
growing and throw them out of my life
cuz I don't agree with their adult
decisions I don't think I can I'm going
be honest with y'all you know if they
were like dling kids or doing something
that like they're harming other people
that's a different conversation in
entirely if they're just doing work I
strongly disapprove of that's not enough
for me to disown these kinds of people
that's me um even if they arming
themselves or people around I can't I
can't go with that I can't I can't like
it's
like so I I can distance myself from
people that entertain certain
relationship that I cannot I can no you
you're dealing with that kind of people
I can't I can't no I can't even be seen
with you I can't chill I can't we can't
we can't be we can't be so you have a
different threshold than me seems like
you even even if they're engaging in
really strong criminal activity that's
harming other people you're not
necessarily willing to push them out of
your life I'm willing to oh you're
willing to your kids not my kids even my
friends I got forget friends I'm talking
about something much more
intimate that's a different relationship
the thing is is is is is is even like
sometimes I can understand like with the
work that we do and stuff like that
would I so so clarify hold on hold on
clarify the question what the question
is it do would I would I distance myself
it doesn't even matter my whole point is
everyone got different lines you may
have a different line what is the
question if they're harming other people
yeah I can okay means depends on what
kind of harm yes they saw somebody is
very different than when they did L kids
sure all is to say some people ex work I
know some parents if they kids doing
that kind of work they're like get out
of my life I'm not one of them people me
partially okay and I say this also for
me I also don't think this is subjective
thing but for me I think when I've had
periods of my life where I didn't have
my parent around especially when I was a
young adult in my 18 right and I'm
joining the military my mom doesn't want
to talk to me anymore because she
doesn't approve of what I'm doing and
also to my mom's credit historical
context at the time 9/11 had happened
recently A lot of people were going
overseas for deployments Muslims felt
some type of way my mom being a Muslim
she felt a lot of type of ways about her
son joining the military and do that
stuff I understood her perspective I
just felt like as an adult I needed to
find my way in life I need to get some
sense of disine but this is the
environment that I was going to find it
in we stopped talking it was a difficult
period when you don't have the support
system of your parents you don't have
that emotional support people backing
you like I remember doing most of my and
I had nobody to call every time things
would get difficult I would watch my
platoon mates go on collect calls to
call their families from the payones and
stuff and I had nobody to call right
that period was a very difficult one for
me and it made our Chasm really
difficult even when we did start talking
it was awkward for years and now we're
at a point where it's different because
she's no longer trying to order me she's
no longer trying to tell me what to do
because she's finally acknowledged oh my
child is no longer a child they've grown
into their own person as adults you got
to talk to people differently and my
some people like yo you can never talk
about your par that way uh yes you
can you know
what my mom is my mom I love her to
death she doesn't know everything she
doesn't always know better sometimes I
have to slap the credit card out of her
hand because she doesn't know what how
bad she's making financial decisions and
I have to do that for her wellbeing
sometimes I have to push her into a car
and drive her somewhere because she
needs to go to a medical appointment for
her eyes because she's too irresponsible
to realize that it's not good to not go
to the doctor you're getting blind
stupid I remember that you know I
love my mom my mom is my mom but she
don't always know better I remember that
oh that was from the heart and I
say that because
was oh this Vision I had of you like oh
it's it's nonsense you're flawed like
everybody else and it's okay for me to
talk about that with reverence and
respect but also with a directness that
shows my love for you and I say this to
say your relationship changes so the way
you approach the dynamic changes the way
you communicate to your parent changes
but also the way the parent communicates
to you changes that's that that's life
that's life you might have a subordinate
at work when they get promoted to
manager you can't talk to them like
they're subordinate no they're your
peers now it's a different relationship
they so I respect the way he approaches
it even if a lot of people are going to
mock him or whatever is going to say
he's going to be much more apt to
protect his daughter from any negative
things that happened going forward than
a lot of people are completely removed
her life in fact he's much more likely
to prevent it because she got that
emotional support system she doesn't
feel like she's isolated from people so
in my
opinion I like this but I'm okay with
also saying I understand where other
people are coming from when it comes to
The Clash of their value system and and
also I I get like
she can more think about it and not do
thing out of spite M just to be like oh
yeah cuz people have a tendency to do
that whenever they don't get the support
that they're supposed to get or the
support that they need they're going to
be like ah yeah word it's no longer
about what they want to do it's it's now
it turned into it switches into I'mma do
it because you don't want me to do it
even further than that it's not even
necessarily because of Spike because the
people who are supporting them are the
people who already living that lifestyle
so all of a sudden you go to the strip
club but everybody else around there is
also supportive to you and very kind to
you so you're like what I'm not getting
at home I'm getting from these people
gang gangs X workk whatever we not name
it yeah it's the same thing but again I
also say this knowing I understand why
people make the different decisions so
where like I have my boundaries I don't
own you I don't control you you're not
mine but I care so deeply about you like
there's not another single human on this
planet that I care to protect more than
you and so that's it's just a safety
thing I appreciate you telling me yeah
and us talking about it I'm glad we're
close enough to have this conversation
I'd rather you know than it's not it's
not up to me you know what I mean you
don't need my approval or blessing I
mean you know I trust you to handle
yourself like my job as your parent is
to teach you how to live without
me that's a
bar that's a
bar hey say what you want about him but
he not lying now some people might say
he failed that's up for a debate in my
opinion if he really had that mindset
that's beautiful I think a lot of
parents think they're supposed to be
parents and guided
forever they think they supposed to make
decisions for you forever I see kids in
their 30s and their parents still
deciding everything yep I respect this
Italians
what different cultures different
perspectives sounds morbid and screwed
up but I don't want to be on my deathbed
in my 90s and having you being like Dad
don't leave I don't know how to do taxes
I'm like I want you to be like I got
this let go you're fine I want to
peacefully you know pass into my death
knowing that you're going to be fine so
I've given you those
tools up to this point for you to just
handle your business it's funny because
I realized that
one of my mom's
pride is not even my
success one of my parents pride is not
one of it's not even my success
one of my mom's pride is the fact that
my sister and I are cool MH so that if
she
goes we got each
other and that's very important that
we're able to handle each other even
Beyond her being there so I think it's
something that you realize and I think
the that goal changed with time you know
it was not always that yeah you know it
was a have a degree have a there that a
big career big money and everything like
that all that changed got when the
perspective came in and then she's not
cool with some of her siblings and then
she sees and she's like nah when she
sees me and my
sister my big homie she's like oh when I
tell my sister we're going to Florida oh
yeah but yo I said we going I didn't say
nothing about the
what I said we going is wrong
with you okay we going just pack your
bags
when my my mom sees that she's y have a
good time we cool we have a good time
have a good time my sister new was good
me was good okay it's like you know my
sister's my sister I'm me we CH we CH we
chilling you know what I mean so it's
like it's cool to have her around and
stuff like that and we don't have like a
beef or whatever I understand people
that doing stuff like that but yeah one
that's one of my that's one of my mom's
Pride when I roll and you guys are
always together well I
mean I pay for the whole like I pay
for the the tickets I pay for the car I
pay for like what we but you guys came
together yeah but the fact but my mom is
like okay you got your sister's back
yeah y y y together and this
had mine yeah got you got
you so that's what you're proud of you
know what I mean so she's yeah she's
proud of
that the one thing that I do want to
make clear is that this is because I
respect myself I want to just do it the
fastest way possible so I have more more
time to do things like rescues and
Charities and help my family and my
friends that need help so this is really
my fault cuz I failed to become a
billionaire that's what it sounds like
too I understand what she's saying
because in her head she's like there's
so many things I want to do and what's
the fastest way I can accumulate wealth
and the dad's thinking think about the
long-term consequences but she's not
necessarily thinking about it like that
I understand where she's coming from and
people can choose to believe her not
whatever it is but from what I've seen I
could see it being true for some people
absolutely absolutely before you became
adult if I'd been a billionaire you'd be
like yep there's no point assets that I
could capitalize on and call them assets
I talk up to my parents like that
sometimes the reason why I'm going to
tell you why is because uh my parents
are very for black people they're very
open okay but there's still some tabos
and because I was when I was growing up
I was left out of a lot of things a lot
of discussions like you always left out
because it's that Bo you can speak about
this but as a child you want to
understand certain stuff and you
navigate life not knowing certain things
that you should have known and you don't
know them because they want to keep it
from you and they kind of forget about
it and there's like a threshold of time
that they should have told you about it
and you still don't know and you act
life not knowing those things and when
you go back
for example there was a beef from my
family okay okay there was a beef in my
family one of my
aunts she married a
man and the family of that man had some
beef with her they never told us about
that so the kids were cool all the kids
of those family were cool but the
parents are not and me I'm walking and
I'm seeing the parents at the moment I'm
like oh hi and I'm walking up to them
and I'm like oh yeah and that how you
guys doing and I feel like the parents
are mad awkward they don't know like
they're like I'm I'm good am might like
stuck up and I just walked in a
situation that I didn't even know about
cuz y'all have a beef they
looking at me funny and they're like who
the why the is this little
talking to me have the
audacity to talk to
me but then I didn't even know that was
a beef okay but when I I asked the
question so what happened to just oh
don't even worry about it there's
nothing you didn't want to tell me about
it or you want to tell me later you
forget about that you don't tell me and
you make me walk in situations that I'm
not even supposed to walk in cuz I'm
supposed Tabo cuz it's taboo so all the
taboos I'm like that you're against
I'm against that stuff so whenever I'm
talking yeah I will talk straight up
about sex with my mom I will start
straight up about I know you know it's
so funny you explained that whole thing
I'm like yeah yeah yeah the taboo I
talk straight I'm like E I know and but
but acknowled also it's me I know and
also also you've seen my parents you've
seen they kind they different they are
different but in my head a parent is
still a parent because my Cal reference
is just my parents and all the parents I
saw growing up and that would never fly
like for example so I get what you're
saying but I'm culturally conditioned I
understand what you're saying like for
example my birthday there was a
background like we did a back barbecue
in my my backyard and everything and
stuff two of our friends went there and
everything stuff and they saw how I
interact with my peeps like two of them
were like yo you speak like that with
your mom it's like yeah and at some
point at some point I was
Blazing my parents was right there I was
like to proty was like yo yo your mom is
right bro your mom is right there my mom
is right where yo mom you want some no
not I don't want any she cool she don't
want any isn't that so crazy people
could see you drinking with your parents
but if you smoke something that's legal
over here they lose their mind yeah it's
funny it's a funny thing it's a funny it
doesn't make sense logically speaking
but we just convince oursel Alissa
please be careful out there that's why I
have boundaries it's because I don't
know 30-year-old me like I know me and I
feel like I'm going to still be okay
with it but I also want to make sure I
have that room to change if I feel like
I want to and I love you and respect you
and support you through all of it so yay
please be uh please be safe like I'm I'm
here for you like through the I think we
got the point uh
no no no way no no no no no I mean
that's me that conversation that's just
no no no no no no no for like a couple
days of denial and then like come talk
to me later let me have a few drinks no
no no no no no no and I'm like all right
let's talk and then she going to be
right in front of me I'm like baby I
love you I wish I had Sons but you're
here we're going to figure this out
you're my only daughter I hope I never
have more
daughters I mean I'm joking but I don't
know I'd be like that would stress me
out I feel
like there's like a bunch of things if I
had children that would stress me the
out my kid says they're going on
deployment I'm like no no no no like yes
I know you're doing in the service of
something greater but it's just like no
yeah you did it too you no no I didn't
do deployment that's does it matter you
went in yeah it was not the same they're
going to use it against you does it
matter yeah it was not the same say you
could have been but but I get what
you're
saying um only fans no no no but if it
was like push come to sh and
she like we got to figure some out
uh but that's a different conversation
difficult conversation I know people
going to meme they're going have it
laugh at him that's cool but like ask
yourself honest question everyone watch
it right now that's your
child how would you handle it and don't
do it from the perspective of like
you're observing someone else's life
think of somebody you love very close to
you engaging in this stuff and how would
you react to it how would you keep them
into your life or not I'd be curious to
hear how you guys feel in the comments
and just I want to see some some some
some good good
responses it's a good thing it's a
conversation but as weird as this
podcast is and seeing these
conversations that I think are generally
private being public I think it's good
for conversation points for everyone
else watching that's that's what a
podcast is let us know what y'all think
all right so get in the comments
anything else let us know